we had our amazing back-to-back
bachelor i can't believe that i get to
be the bachelor again
we had real love stories i am
absolutely completely falling in love
with you
but literally none of them worked out so
we also had heart-wrenching goodbyes
this is your the bachelor greatest
seasons ever episode six
brad womack recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and roses
[Applause]
hi babes it's me lauren zema
oh everybody we are here in our texas
gear to talk about
brad womack this good-looking guy from
austin texas
you're a little too good to be true i
think we've got some stars on
cause lone star state
[Music]
and j.c in a denim moment
with his guitar because country music
chris sand you know this is what she had
in the quarantine
kind of a texas coachella actually
christine that would work very well in
austin which is where brad
womack is from hey ladies
brad womack the only lead ever
to do the show not once but twice
i keep calling him back-to-back brad but
it wasn't i think it was 2007
and like 2011. but we're getting both
seasons in
one episode on the bachelor greatest
seasons ever
greatest seasons ever let's get to it
first of all what did you guys think of
this episode
i absolutely loved it i had never
watched brad's seasons
and i just thought they were both so
good no wonder they asked him back
this was quality television brad was
bold
brad was benevolent brad was
breathtaking brad's a good looking guy
yeah he is uh-huh
i would let him ravish me anytime
but another great b brad was a great
bachelor because he was a successful
business owner and one more great b
he owned bars yes
wonderful own four businesses bars
nightclubs
so in honor of brad and his bartending
bar
owning ways i'm starting off tonight
with a little cocktail
this is called a texas ranch water
it is a favorite cocktail of mine if you
guys don't know it very simple
a little tequila a little fresh lime
juice and a little
toppo chico a favorite mineral water
over there in texas
so brad's night begins and don't drink
every time
bars were mentioned i own a few bars
the ladies are like i can make a drink i
can flip a few bottles i'm a bartender
too
later i drink alcohol i bartend as well
some on the night
don't drink every time i say a b word
back-to-back brad bold benevolent
breath shaking
it's gonna be hard lauren you're talking
about the bachelor
he was beloved
by the women and honestly brad was
the epitome of what we want in a
bachelor to me he was successful good
looking kind
and you know brad kept saying i'm just a
normal guy
i'm just an everyday hard-working guy
that's looking for his soulmate
but he was that elevated normal the guy
everybody wants to date
the bachelor i'm not royalty i'm not a
professional athlete
i mean he's like i'm a normal guy with
my
incredibly chiseled jaw perfect quaff of
hair and beautifully manicured stubble
brad's good looking
[Music]
i feel like kind of like a little bit of
a movie star right now honestly i kind
of thought
brad womack's on movie star level he was
like brad pitt
meets bradley cooper and we're far from
the shadow now
he was in the depths down deep didn't
actually end up with anyone okay
i mean it's funny because texas is the
lone star
state and he looks like a star
wound up alone
brad womack was so amazing even chris
harrison said
how are you here this good-looking guy
from austin texas
who's extremely successful is single
how how are you here so night one right
off the bat
don't drink every time these women talk
about how sexy brat is
we have the sexiest bachelor ever
oh my goodness oh my goodness is right
hey
sexy this good looking guy you know they
told me you were hot but i didn't know
you need a fire extinguisher
oh my goodness he is so cute brad really
checked all the bachelor boxes another b
word oh go
this was about 2007 so i think he was
about 35
really looking to settle down i'm ready
to get down on my knee
propose and a real man of substance with
a lot to discuss
i truly want to find out what they're
all about not what we've had
in recent seasons you know
really spotlit it for me it's been a
minute since we had a lead
who was a little bit older and who
really knew what they were looking for
instead we've been like on the journey
with them to find out what they're
looking for
which is good but it's different and i'm
ready for clear crawly season for that
reason it's like when we've had a couple
similar vibe seasons good for a pivot
you know perfect
pivot and first there's jenny i want to
be the person that you fall in love
oh sweet jenny cheers to her
i mean don't drink every time this woman
is the sweetest she's very giving
generous and loving i want to be the
person that you fall in love
she is always smiling i mean she is
telling him
she loves him and she is crying and brad
is doing everything right and comforting
her
while she is telling him that she loves
him and crying it was like oh my god
i think that i have met the person that
i'm meant to be with i'm really excited
and then there's diana the strongest
don't drink every time diana was strong
i came into it just saying i was just
gonna be myself if you like me like me
if you don't
i'll go home i'm hanging out with my
family that's fair what did you guys
think
of these relationships i felt i was
watching
a movie i felt i was listening to
scripted words i want to be happy as
happy as i've been in the past few weeks
i want this for the rest of my life
it was so beautiful this is going to be
one of the most difficult things i've
done
in my entire life and then it's the
finale
even though we're only halfway there
with the finale
television math okay today by all
accounts has been nothing short of
brutal
and i'm just gonna go ahead and finish
this tequila because what an
ending
yeah i hope you're brad's serving some
stiff drinks at the bar heels
breaking a lot of hearts you know so
brad's talking to jenny
from the first moment i saw you i was
absolutely taken back
by your beautiful smile and you can tell
she thinks it's going well
i want this i want this so bad and then
he takes a turn
and you can see her face fell you
literally see it fall you see her eyes
change
i never thought i'd i'd tell you goodbye
i truly didn't
so why does brad break up with jenny
well he tells her you know everything's
so great
but he wants something more i want
something more
that i can't i can't find with us
and i don't know how this man managed
to say something so savage
and still seems so nice i want
something more it's that texas gentleman
in him
i'm telling you i mean to tell somebody
you're great but i really want something
more
listen to how that sounds when i say it
versus brad i want
something more that i can't i can't find
with us i'm watching a movie star you
know that's what i'm saying the man can
perform
but it's also genuine i think do you
think brad's fake or genuine
because after he broke up with these
women people thought he was pretty fake
it breaks my heart to have to tell you
that
because i feel like the luckiest guy
just has spent any amount of time with
you
i mean when he is talking i really feel
like i'm watching like
a ryan gosling character in the notebook
and and maybe diana's rachel mcadams and
maybe jenny's that other woman from
later i don't know
but it felt like a film i don't think so
what can i do to change your mind do you
agree let me know in the comments below
we got some movie star quality people on
this reality show this season okay
so jenny is just sobbing into his
shoulder and my gut is wrenched
and then it's time for diana and
everybody
if you think about seeing this movie
back when it came out in theaters
you didn't know the ending and you're
probably watching it thinking
well surely he'll pick deanna plot twist
paper you know what i need more tequila
[Music]
that's okay oh that felt like a lot well
you know what are you gonna do
um oh we need lime juice we have a
butter knife for
stirring so that is gonna be
very clear oh god here we go oh yeah
that tastes like tequila
okay
[Music]
and we're back and so diana is here
imagine that you're at home
watching and you know the way the
bachelor works at this point we're
10-ish seasons in so you think brad
dumped jenny
and certainly he'll propose to diana he
even has
an engagement ring
but as brad's starting to talk i just
say goodbye to ginny
and the romantic film you've been
watching becomes a horror picture
he's stressing hold on real quick he's
he's how do guys do this he's
he's unbuttoning his collar
[Applause]
and he's pacing okay hold on real quick
he's pacing he's pacing he's just
walking around this tiny courtyard
what's he doing
where are you trying to go brad where
are you trying to go
you're just in this little court there's
no there's oh that's a hedge oh that's a
stone wall
that's another hedge brad you're stuck
and just like a country song
our texas golden boy with the movie star
good looks tells her he has to quote
say goodbye
i have to tell you goodbye
the horror oh this is
not the notebook no no no i think i got
the parts wrong
diana isn't rachel mcadams brad isn't
ryan gosling
it's that brad is rachel mcadams
and diana is james marston
i don't know but who's brad gonna end up
with now i hate you
who is brad womack's ryan gosling and
ultimately did you understand brad's
explanations
to these women i did not it
he had seemed so happy with both of them
the relationship's
so great and i think that's why it was
such an incredibly shocking finale when
it really aired because not only
had a lead never chosen no one in the
finale but also
he just seemed to have two wonderful
options i don't know brett i don't know
from a romantic film to a horror picture
to a mystery
what's the thriller is how much tequila
i put in here because i
i did not measure that
would it have been false if you had
continued on with diana
we get a little bit of the after the
final rose and bachelor historians do
you know when we started doing those
let me know in the comments below and
chris harrison wants to know
why brad why why did he buy a ring why
did he go through all that and brad
still doesn't know
he mentions not having butterflies for
jenny
why didn't i get the butterflies i don't
know he mentions his gut
feeling being wrong i think for diana i
had a very big
gut feeling that just this just wasn't
right here's my take
don't look too hard for the butterfly
feelings that tends to be kind of an
immature excitement in the very
beginning initial attractions of things
and
it doesn't indicate a long-term
relationship
but your gut feeling i will say
justin
[Music]
trying to process this too still not
really enough of an explanation for me
though considering how far he'd gone
with each of these women
wow look at this oh and now they're here
we're gonna catch up with them on zoom
and don't drink for every one of their
names
joining us now diana papastagliano and
jenny croft bottlato
join us i think that they're both
married now and that they've like done
the hyphenated name thing which is great
it's just
a lot of names he just could not give a
straightforward answer as to why he
decided not to pick
anyone so we catch up with brad
and one more bee his beard
is that is that a corn beard you got
going that's a low maintenance i'm
old and don't tear beard yes brad's
beard is like another character on this
show now
that thing is rough and gruff and tumble
what texas things i don't know i don't
tequila i have no idea why i said that
i don't know what the hell i was
thinking man he still doesn't really
have
answers for us so what did we think of
brad's first season
let me know in the comments below now we
know
that he came back for season two after
and i quote
a lot of therapy three years of very
intensive therapy
i found an incredible therapist and
really analyzed the reasons behind
my phobia of commitment and season two
started with a bang
yes i slapped myself because season two
started off
with a bang
okay okay i'm just the messenger season
two of brad womack's bachelor journey
this was season
15 a couple of years after his first
season what's wrong with
me and don't drink every time brad said
he
worked on himself i found an incredible
therapist
and it took a lot of therapy and it took
a lot of time
more importantly i want to prove to
myself that i've changed i'm a better
person
enough is enough i needed to make a
change
so the question would be
could he finally find the one
the sequel oh another movie the sequel
honestly it's like when you get you know
you want a sequel of a really good movie
great okay and understandably on night
one
these ladies had lots of questions about
brad's plot line you're in this for the
real thing this time right
don't drink for every question they had
for brad
for the real thing this time right i
hope that you're ready to answer a lot
of questions over
and over and over again is it that he's
scared is he is he serious you know what
happened and when did you know
what made you really want to do this all
again so you weren't ready to open up
them but you are
now are you in a good place this group
of women is tough
i am here to find a wife which brings us
to
michelle money i watched your season
and i was very impressed with your
decision thank you
so michelle money was kind of the
villain on brad wolmack's season come
here on out
yeah no talking rather iconic
she told brad she wanted him to send
women home
i think we should go send some girls
home now like specifically
which women and said like he needed to
do it now it's time for him to start
handing out roses and getting rid of
some of these girls here's to a strong
character
i really really like michelle what i
don't like
is when michelle starts questioning my
decisions
but brad is also bold he's not gonna let
her tell him what to do
you called me out on keeping people what
did you think of this whose side were
you on here michelle monies
or brad womacks i was on brad's side yes
i will say that
man i'm obnoxious and then we get an
update with michelle money
well it was really hard to watch because
you're just like and it's really great
to see her because she does what i've
said many
times as the most important thing for a
reality character to do
she owns it she says she was obnoxious
on that season she can't believe it i'm
incredibly obnoxious kind of awesome too
but she's so happy now and we also
caught up with her daughter who had been
in a very
bad skateboarding accident recently and
luckily is doing
well i'm recovering fast i'm doing well
got released from all my therapies
so cheers to michelle money honey
shintel
he dumps michelle and he's walking her
out and he's like
can i hold your hand i have your hand or
not a chance
um probably not no
and michelle gave up as she literally
laid down in the limo and
didn't talk
and some mood i'll be honest i was
watching her thinking
mood and i felt it
yeah okay we gotta keep thank you gotta
keep going
keep going get up lift each other up
let's face it this girl's the entire
package
i like this girl a lot but back to
season 15 and it is brad and ashley
so obviously these two didn't work out
spoiler alert she would go on to become
the bachelorette anyway
tell me about you what makes you you
bragging ashley's conversations again
you guys
i just felt brad asked really good
questions and
had real discussions with these women do
you think you can allow yourself to live
while you're trying to achieve
no okay that's such a great point but i
also think part of it
was the women ashley was very focused on
her career
i know like i'm very career oriented and
like i've made that really clear
but at the same time i want to be
superwoman i want to be able to do
everything
and you know made me think why haven't
we seen
these back and forths on recent seasons
of the show and i think it's because
a lot of people are now going on the
show
to make that a career to be an
influencer and so it's not being
discussed
and it does take a lot of the meaning
out of those chats you know
i'm almost wondering should the show
just allow people to say
i'm on here in part because this is a
career move for me and here's my plan
for myself
let's talk about our life after the show
together what do you think
let me know in the comments below does
the reality
of what life is really like after the
bachelor need to be acknowledged more in
the dating interactions on the show
brad makes me feel like i'm the most
special beautiful
wonderful person in the world but now
we're on the journey with brad and
chantelle
and brad and emily maynard thank you for
doing this it really means a lot to me
i just feel like i've watched about a
million
amazing relationships on this episode
brad i hope your bar
is having ladies night because
you did i do have two women left that i
can see a future with
i've never felt this way and it it
scares the hell out of me
oh but we're on the finale round two and
he is dumping chantal
and here's where it gets tough tell
chantal chantal
and this texas gentleman is still so
sincere
she literally tells him after he breaks
up with her
you're amazing you know you're an
amazing person
i have stronger feelings for someone
else
and i don't just
sucks because i felt so strongly i mean
i'm emotionally exhausted
so many dumpings this is like an extra
amount of dumping is because
it's two seasons in one episode and
it didn't work out in the first finale
so it's like a lot of really intense
dumpings
it's like
[Music]
are you guys feeling kind of emotionally
dead lately
i am personally i know so now it's
time for the e the end day
and also emily and so the question is
what will brad do everyone in america is
watching
with brad baited breath will he
dump her again or will he find his happy
end
thing that's another e word okay you
look stunning
brad is talking to emily and he's
adjusting his collar again brad
why are you reaching for the collar why
are you sweating
sorry are you gonna be running around
stuck again you've got more of an open
landscape this time
no hedges to get caught behind what will
you do brad
you're so much more to me than a leap of
faith you're the one m
and brad proposed
emily please make me happier than i've
ever been in my life and marry me
[Music]
oh you know he did say that the proposal
was genuine and i do believe him but
also he couldn't have gotten two seasons
without proposing to anybody and i'm
saying i mean the man would have just
been like completely hated i mean chris
aaron hasn't even made the joke that he
would have had to move to russia
move to russia or somewhere to continue
with his life so it's like brad had to
propose but also emily maynard's great
so i understand why you would propose
somebody like emily maynard but anyway i
think that's great too i don't know let
me know in the comments below
okay but we know she was not the one hun
yes those two stayed together for a
little while after the proposal
and ultimately did not work out and then
emily became the bachelorette
and that didn't work out either but she
is now married and happy and has a
beautiful family quarantine check-in
cheers
don't drink for every one of her kids
big sister
ever scholar and of course
she still says brad is amazing i have
nothing but good words to say about brad
what do you guys think was brad the most
beloved
bachelor by the women and honestly
whether it's a magical cinematic movie
star spell or not
i was loving brad if you have anything
to say i'd love to hear it
and in my head i was going red for
bachelor
round three and then chris harrison even
suggested it
will you be the bachelor again for the
third time
then brad said no no no and i'm dating
someone
and so that's great no disrespect to
this woman and obviously she thinks brad
is amazing and i'm glad they're happy
together him and her and his beards
that's great
so we have just in time gotten to the
bottom of our tequila
yes a little texas ranch water for the
band who slaughtered a bunch of women's
hearts
sorry that was dark but he did we've
been reviewing a lot of the seasons
ultimately what is your favorite season
of the bachelor bachelorette and
has the greatest seasons ever show
changed your mind on any of that
let me know in the comments below i will
be back in two weeks for a look back at
one of the most explosive seasons in
bachelorette history
next up is ali fitowski season oh
this one was a good one one of the ones
that i kind of watched on and off
we had some amazing characters like
frank
rated r it's gonna be so good and by the
way you guys
i can't believe i haven't been doing
this is the quarantine messing with my
mind
i haven't done any shameless plugs in
quite some time and we have
several to mention i have been
interviewing
every single lead to go with their
episode of the greatest seasons ever
so check out on entertainment tonight's
youtube channel interviews with sean and
kathleen
caitlin and jason jojo and jordan
trista and ryan and and
not a part of the bachelor greatest
seasons ever but i did get the first
on-camera interview with bachelor peter
webber
since his finale also joined by his
lovely girlfriend
our legal eagle kelly flanagan yes the
two of them are in love
they're so happy so you can watch all of
those
and of course tell me what you think as
always i love you babes
so much thank you for watching i am on
tick tock
cameo instagram and we are here with new
episodes of roses and rose
love you bye
is this to texas it's too much
because he's not actually a cow i
shouldn't have this too much i should
take it off because but he's from texas
i don't
know i'm trying to be festive you guys
i'm getting in my house all day i'm not
seeing anybody or
talking to anybody so all i can do is
think of fun costume things
this is chris's no he owns this
i don't know why
that's too much
[Music]
you